[Music]
[Applause]
amy santiago
you have made me the happiest man on
earth i spent one whole dollar on this
ring
will you go on the worst date ever with
me you have to say yes
yes she said yes she said yes
it's for you
[Music]
amy santiago date time time to date
peralta this outfit is ridiculous chop
chop there's plenty of embarrassing to
do and only a few hours to do it in
happy oh yeah you look like every girl
at every bot mitzvah i ever had a crush
on
let's see the bow just like jenny
gildenhorn
why do i wish you had braces should we
get you braces no that's too much
here i go
nice shorts thank you believe it or not
they were not very expensive
do i really have to wear this all night
you know the rules the date starts now
and ends at midnight i decide what you
wear what you eat and where we go
oh and there is one more rule
no matter what happens you're not
allowed to fall in love with me
won't be a problem
a date coming through pay attention
everyone
now i know that tonight is boyle's
big night but let's forget about that
completely for a moment
and admire and comment on every terrible
aspect of
this
permission to go to the bathroom granted
first of three use the mislead
hey congrats again buddy i really am
proud of you
still wearing the metal huh yes i want
women to be impressed by me
oh right well i'm sorry that i can't
stay but i have a
terrible night planned for amy first up
is the mall photo studio where we'll
take our official date portrait the
picture will be the two of us playing
one saxophone
then some peel and eat shrimp for dinner
at a dangerously cheap seafood
restaurant
and then i've contracted a youth choir
to serenade us
[Music]
they'll sing to her at midnight in the
middle of times square she and 500
german tourists
will savor that memory for all times
jake you know why little boys pull
little girls pigtails on playgrounds
cause they're so easy to grab they're
just begging to be pulled because they
like the girls and that's the only way
they know how to get their attention
what are you saying all of this season
this elaborate date
somewhere down deep you like aiming like
like you're like
okay that's straight up insanity how
much did you spend on tonight
fourteen hundred dollars but all of it's
on credit cards so it's like five
dollars a month for the next two
thousand years i do not like amy
you're putting a lot of effort into a
joke why don't you just sit down and
have a real conversation with her okay
boyle you live in your ex-wife's new
boyfriend's basement
i'm not taking advice from you uh excuse
me everyone santiago and i will be
performing the steerage jig from the
film titanic
which we have prepared for in no way
shape or form
romantic no embarrassing milady
do this mini heat your guts channel that
passion into the dance
peralta skully tag in okay keep spinning
you